congratulations are in order oh thank
you recognizing this way by the MBR what
does it mean oh wow
I mean I've they've been they really
kind of changed everything six years ago
silver linings playbook they gave me an
award for acting and it really really
floored me and to be back here again
honored as director to be here with this
gentleman
[Music]
with him
not only the two of them but Dave
Chappelle and Anthony Ramos from Rapid
Gibran and you know Andrew Dice Clay it
was really it was it was a director's
dream to have actors give all themselves
you know we were talking about it you
don't realize you're doing some sort of
public event and then it just hits you
it's very overwhelming well I mean this
is a gentleman who's been in this career
for 50 years and for me to be able to
talk about him publicly I mean go for
Wayne if you guys get this elevator win
we know we went home yeah we got
something to eat
so many people of course with
disappointed
Oh Stan
oh well I mean I'm a huge fan of Graham
King and he worked so hard I was very
happy for him and RAM Emacs incredible
actor and everybody won the thing about
those things it was its incredible room
I was actually able to be there with
Dick Van Dyke and Carol Burnett I mean
Denzel Washington it's crazy
yeah
that's like saying it's insane
[Music]